[Music]
right
a fantasy yeah yeah yeah just now ah
congratulations dear what is the Higgs
boson it is a particle and describes the
stuff about the 12 other particles and
stuff Hey look at that
everything about five sigma miss there's
only 12 fundamental matter particles in
the universe and you're made of only
three of them you know which three no
you guys are made of the up quark the
down quark and the electron so if you
take two up quarks and a down quark that
makes a proton two down quarks and an up
quark that makes a neutron oh that's a
good point then the Higgs interacts with
these particles to give them their mass
so it's it's a particle postulated to
explain why we don't go the speed of
light so light sits through the universe
but they are stopping me from being
great it sneaks of stopping you from
going the speed of light Higgs is
slowing you down like you should love
hate you should love me pink seem like
they're not but you know what see but
that's it lates like you're in a
constant embrace with a Higgs field I'm
saying the Higgs is giving you that
constant hugs you can't get away but
that's okay because it's warm and cozy
with the Higgs now in celebration I'm
going to increase my mass and thereby
increase my interaction with the Higgs
field
thank you really
fantastic we've got the whole universe
in your pocket
happy hates dependent a wash one two
three four six eight eggs eggs eggs eggs
eggs eggs eggs eggs eggs eggs eggs eggs
eggs eggs eggs eggs anything sick sick
sick sick sick sick sick sick sick sick
sick sick sick sick sick sick - eggs
eggs eggs eggs eggs eggs eggs eggs eggs
eggs eggs eggs make 1666 pig's name six
pick six six six six six eight six six
three six eight six six six six weeks
sick sick sick sick sick sick sick sick
sick sick very good they take toys they
can they do this to me ha ha ha